the jurogan experience it's kind of the
fun thing about this business like the
entertainment is like you know you don't
know who your fans are right some of
them are much cool me rest assured much
cooler than i am um i had wound up i
went up in janet jackson's mansion one
one time in miami beach because she like
summoned us
to the mansion summoned how does she do
that she have a horn
yes like it's a shofar really and so
we got a call from uh an agent who was a
mutual friend
and who said janet is in town she's
renting a mansion on the gorse island
yeah that's so long the horse island is
where sal magluta from cooking cowboys
the kings of miami rented a mansion as
well so that's how i knew lugus i'm like
[ __ ] salma glutas mansion rental
mansion so she says she's here recording
an album
she wants to meet you she's a huge fan
and i was like
she
did she think you were the guy from the
smashing pumpkin yeah
i'm the one with the hair does she know
that i'm like not billy corrigan
and who incidentally has at billy on
twitter was he like a [ __ ] investor
in twitter like how did he got at billy
i don't know billy's smart so what
happens is when people go want to want
to tweet at him they go at billy c-o-r
and my name i guess like autofills uh
because they go right past at billy
which he has at billy and so i get all
kinds of
like when they're like upset at how he
treated daisy on wrestling on sunday or
weird i'm like what the [ __ ] is going on
like you're so mean to daisy i'm like
what the [ __ ] is happening like why who
who do you think i am but like um
but like uh we get so janet wants to to
meet you and so
we come to this mansion we're sitting
with her manager at the time was this
great big hilarious dude and we're just
chilling on the couch and all of a
sudden he looks up and all of a sudden
at the top of the stairway a vision
janet jackson she's like in this
beautiful like moo moo was like i don't
know it was just like seeing like a like
nefertiti like like [ __ ] like
cleopatra appear at that we're just all
just like uh there's like you know the
angels are singing and she's beautiful
and so like and she like descends the
staircase you know we're just like this
is incredible
and she sits down
and she is just like the sweetest
like most casual down-to-earth person
and she goes into this story she's like
one morning my phone rings
it's like
four o'clock in the morning and it's
jermaine
dupree not jackson her brother she was
dating germain dupree attempt
and she said and i said baby is
everything okay he says yes i'm coming
over right now there's something you
need to see
and she goes okay it's four o'clock in
the morning shows up at the door
are you sure everything's okay yes
everything's fine baby you've got to
watch this and he hands me a dvd-r
written in sharpie it says
cocaine cowboys
[Laughter]
and i'm like i'm like i'm like i'm with
their my producing partner alfred
spellman i'm just like what the [ __ ] is
happening
what the [ __ ] is happening and she said
and i watched it twice
she put the dvd the bootleg into the dvd
player at four o'clock in the morning
and she watched cooking cowboys twice
and she's like you know when we were
growing up my sister
she was interested in love story and
romance and i was like she's talking
about latoya right now right like we
know too much about this family right
you know so like she's like she like she
goes i loved
you know
mafia stories crime stories scarface
crime incorporated al capone that was my
thing and so i loved it and she wanted
to talk about griselda blanco the
godmother and i'm like this is batshit
crazy so
she says
do you guys like sushi
alfred hates sushi
he says yeah i like sushi
[Laughter]
she says we should go to nobu
and have sushi next week she's like
absolutely love sushi
and we went out
with janet jackson oh my god tanobu and
she's like
and we shared it was it was surreal
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify